- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Rob] So there's a tremendous amount of
excitement about the microbiome at the
moment in part due to the $173,000,000
dollar NIH Human Microbiome Project where
the results catapulted from the pages of
Science and Nature to the cover of
Scientific American to the cover of The
Economist in record time and into public
consciousness. How did the excitements
that we're finding due to the decline in
cost in DNA sequencing over a million-fold
in the last 15 years? The microbes do all
kinds of things that we never suspected.
For example, they determine how attractive
we are to mosquitoes. So you're not crazy
when you go camping. You might really be
10 times as attractive to mosquitoes as
the person you're camping with. They
determine how we respond to drugs. And
they even determine traits like obesity
and a wide range of other diseases have
subsequently been linked to the
microbiome. So a lot of what we're trying
to do at the moment is understanding how
can we map our microbes across our bodies
or across our planet? And the intuition is
here is that as you go to different parts
of the world, you see different species in
different locations that immediately
identify a scene that's coming from one
place or another or another. So with
microbes, it's more or less the same, but
we have the problem that they basically
look the same under a microscope, unlike
these charismatic mega-fauna [sp]. So
instead what we do is we turn to the DNA
to understand them. Now, the Human
Microbiome Project together with a team of
about 400 researchers across the country,
we collected about four and a half
trillion As, Ts, Gs and Cs. But then the
problem with the data is it looks like
this. So this is the first 0.1% of the
first file. There's another 17,000 of
these. It's pretty hard to tell who lives
where in the environment from that, right?
So what we do is we use computational
techniques to develop these kinds of
abstract maps where each point summarizes
all of the complexity in a given microbial
community summed up by its DNA. And two
points close together are more similar in
terms of the evolutionary history of their
microbes. Two that are further apart are
more dissimilar in their microbial
evolutionary history. And so when we do
this, we see automatically emerging these
major patterns where the mouth is very
different from the skin, the vaginal
microbiomes and the fecal microbiome down
the bottom there is distinct yet again.
And so what this implies is that two
samples from the same person can be real
different in terms of the microbes. So
here I'm highlighting one oral sample and
one fecal sample from the first person
with the Human Microbiome Project. So
these are pretty different on this map,
but we only really understood this when we
cross-referenced the data to the Earth
Microbiome Project where we can go out
into different physical environments and
ask what two samples are as different from
each other as the mouth and the gut of
this one person. And so, if we compare
your mouth to being kind of like a coral
reef, you have these complex mineralized
structures covered with biofilms that
maybe your dentist pesters you about. The
microbes in the gut are as far away from
the microbes in the mouth as the microbes
in this reef are from the microbes in this
prairie in Kansas; so essentially,
non-overlapping communities. And what that
means is that a few feet along the length
of your GI tract can make as much
difference to your microbes as hundreds of
miles across the Earth's surface. And what
I'll show you is that the skin which is
like yet another microbial continent, has
tremendous diversity as well both within
you as an individual and between different
people. So this might lead you to wonder
how stable our microbiome is, at least if
we're healthy. And my partner, Amanda
who's--I've got her put up with a lot in
the name of microbiome research. And I
addressed this question by sampling our
own microbiomes every single day for a
period of six months. So when I project
that into a slightly simpler version of
this data frame, basically, the dark
points on this are me. The light points
are her. Now, what you can see when I
start this going, so each frame on this
animation is one day as we move through
this landscape in microbiomes defined by
different people. And you can see
immediately how the skin in blue is much
more variable even within one person than
the other sites. The mouth in green is the
most constant, and then the gut down at
the bottom is intermediate between the
two.
You can also see how we retain our
separate microbial identities through the
six-month period, and that's especially
remarkable when you consider we work
together and have all kinds of
opportunities to exchange microbes with
each other. I'll just rotate this around
so you can see how we retain those
separate microbial identities there. So
all of this might lead you to wonder where
do we get these personally unique microbes
from. And if you have dogs or kids as I
do, you probably have some dark suspicions
about that all of which are true by the
way. So it turns out I can actually match
you up to your dog by the microbes you
share. Now that's not to say that your
microbes are exactly the same as the
dog's. So here what we can see on a map
that includes both humans and dogs is that
every site of the body whether it's the
tongue, the stool, or the skin, the dog
and the human are separate from one
another. And again, you can see that the
dog's skin is very variable just like the
human skin is. But in all seriousness, our
first microbes depend tremendously on how
we're born. And so, this is like we did
with Maria Gloria Dominguez-Bello now at
NYU, looking at microbes of mothers now
before they gave birth and then of their
babies within 20 minutes of birth. And
what you can see in red is the vaginal
communities from the mothers and then in
pink, we have microbes from all over the
bodies including the skin and including
the gut of babies 20 minutes after they
were born. Whereas in contrast, in the
dark blue, we have all the skin
communities from the mothers. And in light
blue, we have all the habitats from all
over the body of babies delivered by
C-section. So what you can see is that if
you're delivered by C-section, you're
denied the vaginal microbes you would
ordinarily have as you pass through the
birth canal. We think that the lack of
that co-evolved microbial community may
explain some of the differences in health
between vaginally delivered and C-section
babies. Of course, the most likely outcome
if you have a kid by C-section is that
your kid will be fine, but there are
slightly somewhat higher risks of all
kinds of diseases including ectopic
dermatitis, food allergies and even
obesity, all of which have now been linked
to the microbiome.
So again with Maria Gloria, we're doing
this trial at the moment to try to figure
out, can you restore the microbial
community to kids delivered by C-section.
And so, what we're doing here is
essentially collecting the vaginal
microbes from mothers then delivering them
to the babies. And this is very
preliminary data at this point, but we are
able to show partial restoration of the
microbial community both in the gut and in
the skin by applying this procedure. And
so, we're hoping to develop this into a
large enough study to develop clinical
recommendations based on this microbial
restoration. So you might be wondering,
“Well, what happens after that?” What I'm
going to show you now is the trajectory of
one child--this is what we did with Ruth
Lee [sp], tracking one child over the
first two and a half years of life. And so
what we're going to be looking at his gut
community. He was delivered vaginally, and
you can see that his initial fecal sample
is up there in the vaginal region with
perhaps a little skin contribution as
well. And so the question is, “How long
does it take him to move through this
landscape towards the adult fecal
community over two and a half years? How
complete is that progression down towards
the bottom? And is it smooth or is it
chaotic?” So what you can see is at some
weeks, he changes a little bit whereas
other weeks, he changes a lot. And
remember what matters on these plots is
the distance from one point to another. So
it really is true that one week to the
next, your kid can look like a completely
different person at least when you compare
the distances between these points to the
distances between healthy adults in the
Human Microbiome Project which are those
points in brown at the bottom. Now, coming
up here is something fascinating. So he
gets antibiotics for the ear infection.
See that tremendous regression of the
microbiome and then the recovery. That
went by pretty fast, so I'm just going to
rewind it for you and play it again. So
what you can see is on administration of
oral amoxicillin for an ear infection, you
see this tremendous regression of the gut
microbiome and during months of normal
development, followed in this case, by
rapid recovery.
Then by the time he gets to two and a half
years, he's more or less in the healthy
adult distribution. But we just don't know
in general what the effects of antibiotics
are on the rest of the body and on the
sites they're targeted and whether those
early life changes can have profound and
lasting effects. There's some evidence in
both humans and experimental animal models
that early life antibiotics in the first
six months can lead to increased rates of
obesity, but we don't know about the
impact on the skin, on the mouth and on
other sites on the body yet. We can also
do this sort of thing cross-culturally. So
here in which we have gotten and we've got
an African population in red, South
American population in green and then the
US population in blue, the gut communities
converged on one another after the first
three years of life. However, where they
wound up in the three populations was very
different. So the rate of approach to the
adult stage is very similar
cross-culturally, but the final stage
where you end up can be very different.
And you can see the Western population in
that right-hand panel in blue is very
different from the two non-Western
populations. And in that respect, it's
important to remember that even
large-scale projects like the Human
Microbiome Project have largely only
looked at healthy Western adults. And as
soon as you start to go into children and
as soon as you start to go to non-Western
populations, you see very different
things. This is true not just in the gut,
but in every site in the body. So for
example, this is what we did with Maria
Gloria Dominguez looking at previously
uncontacted Yanomami in South America. And
what you can see is the Yanomami
population is more diverse in the skin, so
that's the left panel, than the US
population. And then the microbes that
they have on the skin are completely
different. So those green points separate
completely from the yellow points of the
US population.
So this might lead you to wonder, “Well,
we've seen that the skin can vary
cross-culturally, but how does it vary
over the human body?” And this is like
we've been doing with Pieter Dorrestein
here at UCSD in the Skaggs School of
Pharmacy. And across the skin, it's just
so fascinating. It's this interface
between ourselves and the physical
environment that we're in contact with. So
Pieter was interested in how microbes were
over the skin. So he recruited two
subjects one of which was him, and sampled
the skin at 500 sites over the body and
then analyzed each of those sites using
two kinds of mass spectrometry. And
re-sequenced the DNA of the bacteria to
give a readout of where they are all over
the body. And one thing that was
fascinating is that all of the microbes
can differentiate the two subjects from
one another. They're not nearly as
distinct subject to subject as the
metabolites are. So you can see that the
metabolites from these two completely
separate clouds, one from the male in blue
and one from the female in red. And so,
the metabolites we can track down where
they are in the body. And some of them are
broadly distributed all over the body.
Some are localized to the armpit or to the
groin or to the toenails or other
particular sites. And we can do the same
kind of thing for the microbes. So for
example, staphylococcus is mostly in the
moist regions like you'd expect so the
nose and feet. Propionibacterium are on
the head and shoulders and corynebacterium
broadly over the body. So one thing that
was really fascinating about this was when
we built these molecular networks to try
to figure out how the chemicals related to
one another, what we could see is that
most of the chemicals we found on human
skin did not come from pure bacterial
cultures or from human skin cell cultures,
but instead came from beauty products. And
in fact, 90% of chemicals that we
identified on skin in the study came from
sunscreen and moisturizer and shampoo and
other things that our subjects applied to
their bodies. So that's just fascinating,
right? That 90% of the identifiable
chemicals on your body probably come from
consumer products that you apply. So to
address this problem, I've been working
with the Hadza in Tanzania together with
Jeff Leach through the Human Food Project.
And so, these are people who have not been
exposed to any of these products at all.
And essentially, what we've been doing is
sampling a wide range of things there
including the gut, the skin, the various
dwellings and so forth on different
projects. And so what you can see is that
the Hazda, shown here in yellow, have very
different metabolic communities from the
Westerners even when we were out at the
field site. So we're at the same location,
but you see these very different skin
metabolite profiles. And what you can see
is of the metabolites that we saw, only
about 25% of what was identified was
shared by the Hadza skin and the skin of
Westerners. You can also see that the
Hadza skin is much closer to the
environmental samples, mostly water
samples that we collected on-site in green
there. They also have a fairly large
contribution from honey which can make up
a lot of their calories in the dry season
which is when we were doing the sampling.
And we can also see a number of plants
that are contributing to the Hadza and not
to the Westerner metabolites. And so these
are things like baobabs and other major
sources of food that we can track down the
specific metabolic links between the food
and the person. So this is a kind of
molecular network where essentially you
can think of this as basically being like
constellations of the different
metabolites where you connect up the ones
that are related to each other and match
them up to different kinds of
environmental samples. And so what we can
do with this is we can identify clusters
that their specific to particular niches.
So for example, we can see plant
flavonoids. We can see monostearate which
is more on the healthcare products in the
US population. And we can zoom in and for
example, look at the flavonoids and how
the profiles are somewhat similar, but
then with subtle differences between the
US and the Hadza individuals in the study.
And then similarly, we can do this sort of
thing with seterols which again are mostly
coming from plant metabolites and from
sucrose from the beehive which is found
predominantly in the Hadza. So we can also
do this sort of thing looking at the
bacteria. And what I'm doing here is just
coloring it by body site. So for example,
the green is stool. The pink is skin, and
you can see this tremendous heterogeneity
in the skin. And we also got some samples
from three collaborators at the Yerkes
Primates Center, and I'm just going to
make some of the balls bigger for the
chimpanzees. Those of you familiar with
chimpanzee anatomy will understand why.
And so, what you can see is that the fecal
samples from the chimps are distinct from
the fecal samples from the humans. Then
correspondingly, the few skin samples we
have from one chimpanzee individual, those
large pink balls, are substantially
distinct from the skin samples from any of
the humans including the Hadza. And then
within the human population like you can
see here basically the gray samples of
skin are samples from Westerners, and the
colored balls are from Hadza from
different camps. And you can see that
again, like the South American Yanomami
group I showed you before, the Hadza skin
samples are distinct from what we see in
Westerners. So we're just starting to
uncover the links between microbiology and
different lifestyles. I should point out
that most of this data from the Hadza and
from the chimpanzees was assembled over
the past week, and many of these figures
we made last night on the spot, so this is
still very preliminary data. We're still
trying to fully understand the results. So
anyway, one thing that's exciting about
matching up the metabolite and the
bacterial profiles is we can get an idea
of what bacteria are doing what functions.
So if I show you something like
proprionibacterium which is mostly on the
head and shoulders and then--sorry, mostly
on the head and shoulders and then
something like oleic acid which is on the
head and on the hands. You can see in the
third figure that oxidized oleic acid,
which is a metabolic product of oleic
acid, that's on the head where you see
proprionibacterium but not on the hands
where you don't see it.
And then similarly with palmitic acid, we
can see it getting degraded to monoolein,
monopalmitin only with proprionibacterium
mostly. So what we can do then is we can
test that hypothesis by taking the
bacteria cultured off skin, and then
incubating it with a precursor and just
verifying that that particular bacterium
in the lab can do the chemical reaction
that we attribute to it. Okay, so I'm just
going to talk very briefly about how we
exchange our skin microbes with our
environment. And for example, we can match
up the keys on your computer keyboard to
the tips of your fingers and the palm of
your hand with your computer mouse with up
to 95% accuracy based on the microbes you
share. So this came out in the scientific
journal PANS a few years ago. Here, I'm
just showing you the skin of the
fingertips from the keyboard keys
clustering together by subject for three
different people. But more importantly, it
was on the TV show, CSI: Miami so you
really know it's true. In any case, we can
use this kind of mapping technique towards
sources of pathogens in the kitchen where
you can see in that top panel that you're
leaving your skin communities primarily on
the door handles and the trash can and
other things that you touch. We can do the
same kind of thing in bathrooms. So here
you can see that the skin's mostly on the
door handles and the toilet seats. Our
stool's fortunately mostly confined to the
bathroom. Then there's a big signal from
soil on the floor and intriguingly also on
the flush handle where apparently, a lot
of people were using their feet to flush.
And coming from New Zealand, I had never
heard of this cultural practice, but
apparently it's fairly common in the US.
We can also do the same sort of thing in
homes. So this is what we did with Jack
Gilbert looking at what happens when you
move into a new house, and you can imagine
some different scenarios. So for example,
you might stay the same, and the house
might stay the same.
You might unpack your microbes all over
the house with the rest of your
belongings. Maybe the house instead
contributes microbes to you, or finally,
maybe you and the house blend into a new
community state. One thing we saw was that
the house microbes were very highly
correlated with human microbes from the
same dwelling. There was one case where
there were two lodgers--sorry, where there
was a couple and a lodger, and to
everyone's immense relief, the two people,
the couple were more similar to one
another in their microbial community than
either was to the lodger. And so there was
no difficult explaining to do. But one
thing we can do is we can track the
individual contribution to different
surfaces. So here what we're looking at is
each individual and each dog's
contribution to different surfaces like
the bathroom doorknob, the bedroom floor
and so. You can see that black line.
That's where person one went away on a
trip, and you can see their particular
contribution to all of these surfaces
disappearing during that period when
they're away. So we can even tell who's
inhabiting a particular space by the
microbes that they're leaving behind. But
more seriously, we can apply this sort of
thing in the hospital environment to where
the hospital acquired infections. And we
can also apply these techniques to really
compelling questions in animal health. So
for example in the Earth Microbiome
Project, we've been looking at a huge
number of different microbial samples so
over 30,000 samples provided to them by
members of the community. And for example,
looking at komodo dragons--so this is me
swabbing a baby komodo dragon at the
Denver zoo called Bintang. What we can see
is that each komodo dragon in their
enclosure shares a whole lot of microbes
with the particular enclosure it's in just
like we do as humans with the enclosures
in which we capture ourselves. But what's
fascinating is that the microbial
communities of the captive komodo dragon's
soil don't resemble at all the communities
that we see in soil in the wild. So you
see these two completely distinct clouds
of points. And what's interesting is the
degree of sharing is pretty similar to the
degree of sharing we see between humans
and pets in the same houses, but not the
degree of sharing that we see with wild
amphibians and their environment where a
constant input of microbes seems to be
really important for health.
Speaking of amphibian health, one thing
that's really important is this fungal
disease called Bd which is leading to
amphibian declines worldwide. And one
thing that's fascinating--and this is with
Val McKenzie at Boulder--is that we can
look at a whole lot of different
amphibians and actually put them along
this axis of resistance from the least
resistant to the most resistant to Bd
based on the skin microbial community. And
then the really cool part is like Rich
showed you in humans, we can actually
transfer the microbes from one frog to
another and confer resistance to the skin
fungus. And so, this idea of microbial
transplants is turning out to be
incredibly compelling. So I'll just wrap
up very briefly by mentioning that you can
put yourself on these kinds of microbial
maps now through this project called
American Gut, that will also accept skin
and other samples. And not everyone wants
to know what's in there, these middle
schoolers reacting to the idea we're going
to use robots and lasers to look at their
poop. But just to re-orient you on the map
in cases like clostridium difficile, what
you can see is this extreme dysbiotic
microbial community if you have this
profound form of diarrhea where you're
going to the bathroom many times a day. I
just want to show you what happens when
you do ecosystem restoration where you
have one donor who's down on the healthy
state there and transmit that to four
patients. So this is with Mike Sadowsky
and Alex Khoruts of the University of
Minnesota. And what you can see is that on
transmission of that microbiome from the
healthy donor to the four of these
patients, and each frame on this is just
going to be one day in the life of the
microbiome. What you can see is
essentially immediately, they go from the
unhealthy stage into the healthy stage,
and then they stay there. And so the
prospects to do this kind of thing--and
this is [inaudible 00:23:59] to clinical
remission of their symptoms within a day
or two.
The ability to do this sort of thing in
all body habitats whether it's the gut or
the skin or elsewhere is an incredibly
compelling area of medicine today given
the large number of diseases we now know
are linked to the microbiome. But what we
really have to do is develop not just
these microbial maps, but the kind of
microbial GPS that tells you not just
where are you right now but where do you
want to go in terms of your microbiome,
and what do you need to do step by step in
order to get there. We need to develop
this and make it so easy to use that even
our children can use it. So you can
imagine the kind of smart toilet that's
going to do an analysis of your microbes
and your metabolites. It's going to
deliver it to your smartphone which, let's
face it, I bet you're using it in there
anyway. And it's going to tell you whether
you're going in a good direction or a bad
direction and maybe what, specifically,
you need to do in order to improve the
health of any of your microbiomes whether
it's your gut or your skin. So with that,
I'll briefly thank again the many people
who contributed to the specific week I
showed you, the large number of amazing
people I've had working with me in my lab
currently and formerly, and finally,
thanks for your attention.
♪ [music] ♪